hey guys on episode 5 of trash talk
you're going to see me yelling at deer
hey bambi you're not getting it bro
talking to a wise old man
that's why i'm studying that's right
buying expensive lemonade
and finding some rad ash
trash talk episode 5 and the lincoln
tunnel
wasn't supposed to be in this tunnel but
drock forgot the battery so we had to go
to the office
that's rock runner it's a little bit of
a later start little town wide
sale and that's the big thing you want
to google search town
wide garage sale because when you can
get 50 or 60 or 30 or 50 or 100
sales together in the same area you get
way more efficient than driving 10 15 20
minutes
to every sale one of the things when you
see four or five different town wide
sales it's cool to
set check google the town and check the
medium
income because when the medium income is
higher and there's more affluence in the
town
it's more likely that they're going to
sell off more expensive stuff
than let's say a town that's more middle
class or lower middle class
than let's say upper middle class or
extremely affluent
and so a couple little tricks here to
start episode five
let's get into it now
[Music]
what's up good news yeah we're out about
oh yeah yeah you have instagram no
what's that i like your prediction on
instagram
you like it that was a good one i've
never found a star a
buck sprayer mug
i'm out hunting
i can't wait that zelda game was so cool
how crazy was that yo getting close
to the house how's the action look it's
few tables someone just pulled
the balls when they're going in they
look like real they got real skulls
somebody pulled up to the garage down
you feel like they have skills
yeah they know what they're doing god
damn it if that guy walks out with like
a nintendo in package i'm going to kill
direct self but like do something luke
you're like robin out here like when
batman's like stuck because
the joker screwed up you got to go do
something about it
i literally think i'm a good driver
because garage sales you have to be so
observant
plus i'm from the old school
pre-internet free smartphones i was just
like looking for signs
kids practice the k-turn when you first
get your license
and it's for this reason i was a k-turn
champion i like what i'm saying
this budweiser signs a fortune doesn't
have a year on it or anything
it's a nice one though what's 10
10 for it that's cheap
would you consider 5 for this
what else you see anything those aren't
everything nah trolls suck
one of the things that people don't
realize is silence is a huge
negotiation tactic if you now notice
back to last week and now this week
right off the bat
i just go silent and in that silence
they have to now start thinking and they
have to decide if they want to get rid
of it
all right i think we go
i mean this budweiser thing is eight
all right blue gross eight is worth it
and i was gonna go seven there but then
i was just like
i kind of like the guy it's rad but i
gotta get rid of some stuff
you can't keep everything right there
you go
five six seven eight have a great day
guys take care
stay well hello all right right off the
bat
we got them we paid hold up lou hold it
up
we paid eight for this vintage budweiser
light which i'm feeling real real real
good about
right off the bat we got a big one
that's the kind of thing you put on
facebook marketplace
or on craigslist and wait for a
collector to come or craigslist
and go 50 to 75. i mean that's a that's
a 50 profit right off the bat
things feel very overpriced but one of
the things that tend to not be
overpriced is stuffed animals
but they're pretty overpriced here percy
kisses does well
the hello kitty's legit build a bear
hershey kiss is collectible but i don't
know
how are you how are you good hi old
yankee mugs
96 yankee mugs four bucks everything's
expensive
[ __ ] here now i just noticed they
negotiated
so are these four each
um i could do two for five if you want
two for five
okay thank you thanks so much take care
guys bye-bye
all right just picked up this uh 1996
vintage
yankees mug world champs uh
picked up two for five bucks she wanted
four each
she didn't get it she got five for two
250 a pop let's look him up
by the way to answer a couple questions
that have been popping up um
when i'm out in the trenches out there
i'm searching my phone for
ebay auctions through the ebay app i'm
looking at completed auctions and
completed and sold
those are two filters that you can
create when you search on ebay
couldn't find the yankee mugs on to the
next sale oh cookies hello
another strikeout strike one strike two
strike three
[Music]
wow wow how are you
good morning i will take this south park
thing for sure
south park fan i definitely feel good
about my south park bye
i'm dying to see what this south park
stuff is i think i stole it
seven south park plush for five bucks
look at the deer look at the deer oh
no this deer is trying to get my money
hey bambi hey bambi you're not getting
it bro
i'm getting it bambi i'm getting it
that's right
you better run this one feels like a
moving set this one okay get in here go
on
inside
lou turn off the car student film time
this whole section here is two dollars
this is a pleasure how are you i'm great
good
very good wow i'm uh out hustling early
i love it
i'm impressed brother from westchester i
love you don't have i know you don't i
know mug life all day thank you brother
yeah sure
thanks good luck thank you
section right here right up into the
house then there's a whole dollar and
five dollars
thank you brother these phones for two
bucks are money
like real
there you go thank you thank you
i was like i gotta i brother stop i
gotta turn around for a second i haven't
i do this [ __ ] on ebay
and and and mugs are great how do i
scale something like this what do i
gotta do
because i'm by my i'm by myself i mean i
can do hot wheels
i can do a mug here i mean between my
time my effort my energy i'm online two
hours a day it's
it's it's hard to scale unless you're
buying
super bulk from china this is a this is
a 101. yeah
this is the one that gets you from this
is the one that can get you
like first of all the weight of scale is
to buy everything like
you you and i bought the fair look at my
house and fill up your house and fill up
my house
and then hire five dollar six dollar
hour
you know immigrants kids someone like
but like we're being very choosy right
now
but everything there that was like the
phone we just bought from att
that's 20 bucks we paid two like i
normally don't buy that
like last episode i was very selective
to the things i want i'm just trying to
teach people yeah
like this house right here there's 400
to be made right but you have to buy
every [ __ ] thing i know but then i'm
sitting there i got to take pictures i
got it
i got i don't want something but it
doesn't sell i don't mind i get shipping
and i guess
it's just i'm going to sit with this
stuff i get some dreidel mugs
i get it and to me the question becomes
how much room do you have in your house
and how much do you love it and how much
do you need 30 50 100
me too me too that's it that's it i mean
i'm in
do you have a basement attic a garage
yeah fill the [ __ ] thing up
we'll punch you in the face i get it but
that becomes the game
that's it that's it that's it all right
all right brother hey thank you so much
take care really a pleasure my pleasure
stay with us go jet i still think we've
missed out on like some rare gem
already because what about this grassy
plain right here it feels
underutilized i feel like i should buy
this and flip it
all right what up trash talk people we
picked up this
phone this att retro phone i picked it
up because i wanted to prove to people
there's a lot more money to be made i
don't normally pick up phones and
electronics
but they're such easy flips pay two for
this phone
whoa a lot of them sold look at this
have a great day i'm just snooping
all right we're a couple hours in and
we've gotten cold on these sails sales
which is not fun
time matters drock
hello how are you
i'm super well um video games
mugs mugs
no video games no she sold them i think
just now
oh no i want to buy these pencils in
pencil flight i'll take this
for 25 cents you know about this right
let's just
here we go ready what are we doing i'll
show you
you hold it like this okay all right
i'll go first
[Music]
this is called pencil fighting it was
huge in in the 80s
[Music]
does it normally take this long yeah
he's doing it he's like cheating
what do you mean i'm cheating he didn't
do it that time are you sure
i'm in trouble
[Music]
[Applause]
i see you dear i see you dear
i know what you're trying to do you keep
beating i keep hustling
i love making dear my rival
we're fairly cold let's see if this
mixes it up have a great day guys
take care bye-bye how much is this
take care bye bye bye
[Music]
what's called a christmas cookie jar
with an 80 retail sticker that we bought
for three bucks
that hopefully goes for 20. just picked
up this uh cookie jar
for three dollars let's see what it's
worth
have a great day guys
hi how are you i hit the studio
i'm finding more fans than [ __ ] stuff
i'm trying to fight
all right
how much is the mug
thank you hello do you want more mugs to
have more money
yeah i'm into mugs
they're a buck a piece yeah okay five
minutes later now that i've hit the mug
life
i can switch t-shirts
and winnie the pooh is always in play an
original pound puppy
let's go pick this uh disney mug tree of
life mug
up for a dollar look what it goes for me
park tree of life yeah
completed shows me how many of that item
have sold
and how many have not sold sold when you
have the sold
part shows me what they've actually gone
for so the screenshots that you're going
to see edited here
a lot of times are coming right from my
phone recordings
and it shows prior auctions what they've
sold for
this 18. that's amazing i mean like
made 40 on that two bucks in two seconds
how much are these the skylanders
yeah you're welcome
okay would you take seven for the bag
what up bro
how are you doing good you're not
filming right i'm filming i'm always
filming
have a good day how's it going let's go
check it out let's go jessie's right yes
awesome man have a good time
how are you doing good yeah really good
good bro
paid seven for a huge collection of
skylanders
the bag itself is gonna be worth more
there's two bags lou there's like 30
figures
i think we crushed this one how much are
stuffed animals
two dollars that's the original pop-up
is that what it is it's cool i'll do
i'll do these as well
okay that's two dollars choose each
other dude can i get the uh
the clothes yeah all right you have
another bag potentially
i'm so pumped right now thank you take
care
bye-bye very accomplished man right now
i'm on fire now let's go
all right just went off got seven
stuffed animals for
we're five for seven dollars a wrinkles
an original popple give me that
a garfield original cabbage patch a
original 85 cabbage patch b original 85.
there's some other things oh yeah
cabbage patch accessories
how much are the stuffed animals great
thank you thank you so much
have a great day picked up these two
two ugly dolls for a dollar
each ten bucks
holy cow this one's 23.
how much is the lamp oh i'm not sure
no you don't want to sell your money
is it are you selling the land you
shouldn't sell it if you don't want to
sell it
you know what i mean i know but it's
well what do you do with it does it sit
in the garage garage
that would be that would be more that
would be more of a reason to sell it
that's what happened
if it was like in your living room and
you like looking at it and thinking back
to a
brighter day then that's then you should
keep it right
are you interested in selling it all
right how much do you want to give i
don't know
as little as humanly possible of course
yeah three
okay okay no i can't i thank you you
want to go inside
you should you should keep it but clean
it up and put it in your house
and enjoy it ten bucks
i'd give you five macs
i don't know the attachments i can't do
it
you got no worries i'm proud i'm
actually proud of you
super well thank you have a great day
thank you guys
[Music]
how do you like my luck mug life t-shirt
t-run
pretty good thank you
pokemon cards yeah but
one of the great games of all time drock
banana [ __ ] grams
you can use it as a phone stand too gary
v do i need good equipment
no [ __ ] use a banana peel how
much of the pins
which one all of
[Applause]
four them how much how many two dollars
two dollars
that's my collection it's very cool it's
a nice collection
yeah i don't like the dolphins two
dollars yeah i hate dan marino
i hate dan marino i'm a jets fan no you
but that's why i'm selling it
what do you think
i would do a dollar for it if you want
to sell it
okie doke
[Applause]
whoops thank you brother bye guys have a
great day bye bye take care my friend
what's up bro blow up my spot
how are you thank you so much yeah man
how's it going today
find anything oh i just found a
playstation one
let's go like 10 bucks that's what's up
how much do they go for oh they go for
like 40 50.
love it thank you so much oh man y'all
don't worry right now
what's your name uh tommy tommy nice to
meet you bro i watch all your stuff
thank you bro thank you take care of
yourself stay well keep hustling
got this retro super mario bag he wanted
three
he didn't get it paid a buck like what
something a vlog on youtube
when my son pulled away he said that's a
youtuber that's that's me it's true
how's the sale going today pretty good
getting rid of some stuff
what are these i don't know
it's on the whole set
those are the guys that's them we know
those guys
we do yes we've seen them twice i love
it
straight yeah i know that [ __ ] guy
i love it i'm positive i know that guy
you're out there
hello hi i'm interested in a large
lemonade please
um would you like ice please
okay can i give you 20 for a large
lemonade
is that allowed yeah you cool with that
thank you so much
keep the change have a great day you're
welcome
you're welcome dirty
hi hi hey gary i am can i have a picture
with you
you can my father's a big fan of you
thank you he's an entrepreneur
tell my son what's up but i live in new
york i hate to bother you i bumped into
earlier yeah it's kind of like losing my
mind are you gary vee
i am oh my god it's a pleasure to meet
you thank you nice to get a picture
ready
hi i'm jackie nice to meet you jackie
uh can you turn this on like it's uh
walk out again
thank you so much thank you so much for
this three one
two three perfect awesome nice to meet
you guys yeah take care guys good luck
thank you you too got it yeah oh he
picked up a book that he just found yeah
earlier first
one for 600. so what show me yeah watch
it
yeah a dollar for you you found this
book we can pick that up as a joke
yeah for a brother that's it's listen
for success
hundreds have you seen sold um yeah i'm
looking up right now
awesome yeah that's awesome have fun
guys take care
i was about to punch him and steal his
book
[Laughter]
yo before i go into the recap you know
we got that mug life swag
how about this limited edition out of
only 500 t-shirts they'll be coming soon
details to come in the commentary do we
have links for this yet are we selling
them yet
limited edition mug life swag coming
soon links
in the description in youtube if we've
got paid three bucks for this christmas
tree
paid five for this south park plush
collection
paid seven for this skylanders
collection
paid eight for this vintage budweiser
light
pay the buck for this starlight ferrari
paid five for these two vintage yankee
mugs
pay two for these ugly dolls paid a buck
for this
super mario vintage bag paid a dollar
for this vintage popple
oh work again
it's poppling bro this is nasty look at
this you see what i just did
paid a dollar for this vintage garfield
beanbag bought these five bugs for five
bucks
stole them because it's [ __ ] mug life
out here
picked up this phone for two bucks paid
two dollars for this vintage cabbage
patch
paid two dollars for this vintage
cabbage patch
paid a buck for this vintage pound puppy
i love dogs that i can flip
paid a buck for this mug
paid a buck for this disney parks
haunted house or animal kingdom mug
paid a buck for this disney parks it's a
small world
mug paid a buck
for this disney mug winnie the pooh is
always in play
subscribe to our youtube channel right
wrinkle right
start of the day life is what you make
make it what you
[Music]
baby